mathieu c'est l'intérieur oui ben ouais
quand tu mets la langue castaldi tient
pas dans jamais en plus au cinéma il ya
plein d'histoires sahara ip pour 2 bat
bien sûr après ce comédien qui
occupaient un jour complet puisque dans
la nuit c'est comme dans la vie
facebook ou disparu dans des eaux moment
ils sont filmés ou à ils ont vraiment on
fait des choses réellement quoi papa
pour de faux moi je vais vous dire un
truc il aura quand même ici n'a je
racontais l'histoire personnelle
50 ans j'étais en
huit ans c'est monotone je faisais une
caméra cachée un jour j'ai fait une
caméra cachée genre où je devais
embrasser une fille naît
et et ont bel et bien finalement on a
fini ensemble
we should i donc voilà et c'est au
départ ce n'était pas du tout le bail
1,8 au pas voilà donc je vous dis c'est
pas bon ok mais boucher cette histoire
est basée sur les chiffres de l'insee
75% des gens se rencontrent sur le lieu
de travail donc c'est pas que cinéma
c'est par avocat lui continue toujours
pas très long
franchement là le repas proposé d'aller
à new york avec jean temps là bas ça
c'est vrai ah bah oui c'est vrai il est
venu voir pendant la pub avait plutôt à
lons et vous montrera bieber
il me fait un peu peur il est venu mort
il m'a dit tu puisses tu commences à
m'exciter nom
et ou dalmat vrai parce que je vis je
trouve que tu es très sexy ouais c'est
vrai il est à quelque chose tu es
quelque chose d'intelligent de sexy
christian bale à new york mais bon pour
rien faire pour s'amuser et il ya un
truc sexy je reviens vers toi toi ils
sont cools aussi ça va vous sinon en ce
moment oui ça va
quand même ça a pas l'air de marcher
pour lui et ses filles peut être qu'il
serait temps qu'ils échangent
d'autoroute
c'est vrai que l'accès combiné serait ce
pas le moment de prendre un itinéraire
de
voir venir et c'est la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence ma poule expliqué ne
l'écoutent pas de difficultés
s'est compliqué la vie n'est pas facile
cette proposition ah bah oui avant le
bas n'ont pas fermé à l'avenir est à
l'être humain peut pas du tout comme
vous je connais bien guillaume il est
fermé un choix d'hier il veut faire un
test comme castelnau est fermé comme un
mythe